Tenemos la ecuación
12 elevado a la - 2 por 1 entre 72
todo esto elevado a la quinta potencia
igual a 2 elevado a la "a", por 3 elevado a la "b".
Y bueno lo que queremos hacer es que esta ecuación se cumpla para un valor de "a" y para un valor de "b",
y para esto lo que vamos a hacer
es tratar de utilizar todo lo que hemos aprendido acerca de las leyes los exponentes,
para llegar a una relación entre esta expresión de aquí
y esta expresión de acá.
Y bueno lo primero que se me ocurre,
es que la parte de la izquierda de esta ecuación
este 12 y este 72,
vamos a intentar expresarlo
en potencias que tengan que ver con 2 y con 3,
para que así tengamos las mismas bases,
tanto la base 2 como la base 3,
y podamos igualar sus potencias.
Por ejemplo, aquí tengo al 12
y el 12 lo podemos ver como 3 por 4...
como 3 por 4,
y bueno el 2 está elevado a la potencia -2,
así que esto a su vez
está elevado a la potencia - 2
y date cuenta que aquí el 3, bueno,
claramente ya es una potencia de 3,
mientras que el 4
claramente también ya es una potencia de 2,
porque el 4 es exactamente lo mismo
que 2 elevado al cuadrado.
Y bueno de hecho justo ahorita
voy a escribir al 4 como 2 al cuadrado,
pero bueno,
antes quiero fijarme también en 1 entre 72
y date cuenta que esta parte de adentro, 1 entre 72
lo podemos escribir de la siguiente manera.
Esto es lo mismo que 1 entre...
y 72 lo voy a ver como 8 por 9...
8 por 9
y bueno todo esto,
todo esto, está elevado a la quinta potencia.
A esto lo voy a multiplicar
por esto elevado a la quinta potencia,
y ahora quiero que te des cuenta algo muy padre.
8 tiene que ver con una potencia de 2,
de hecho es 2 al cubo
y 9 también tiene que ver con una potencia de 3
de hecho es 3 al cuadrado,
y justo eso lo voy a utilizar en un ratito
y esto tiene que ser igual a 2 a la "a" por 3 a la "b"
y para no estar copiando esto siempre,
solamente voy a trabajar con la parte izquierda
y ya que tenga todo relacionado
con potencias de 2 y con potencias de 3,
entonces va a ser el momento ideal de traer esta
parte de aquí e igualar los exponentes
pero, ahorita vamos a trabajar
solamente con la parte izquierda.
Ahora, hay una propiedad de los exponentes
que nos dice que 2 números multiplicándose
elevados a una potencia, es exactamente lo mismo que la multiplicación de cada uno de estos números,
elevados a esa misma potencia,
es decir, que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 elevado a la potencia -2,
a la potencia -2
por...por 4... por 4...
elevado a la potencia -2...
elevado a la potencia - 2.
Y bueno,
justo ahorita voy a escribir a este 4,
a éste de aquí
como 2 elevado al cuadrado,
y ahora fíjate que esta expresión de aquí...
esta expresión de aquí y déjame tomar otro color...
esto que tenemos aquí adentro
es exactamente lo mismo
que escribirlo de la siguiente manera,
por "a" y voy a abrir un paréntesis,
y en lugar de poner 1 entre 8 por 9,
lo voy a escribir como 1 entre 8
1/8 por un 1/9
y al final por una multiplicación de fracciones,
estas 2 expresiones son equivalentes,
y todo esto elevado a la quinta potencia.
Y bueno lo padre es que el 4,
ya lo podemos ver como una potencia del 2,
entonces justo ahora te lo voy a escribir,
como aquí tengo 3 elevado a la -2...
a la -2
y el 4 es exactamente lo mismo
que 2 elevado al cuadrado,
entonces esto por 2 elevado al cuadrado
y esto a su vez,
está elevado a la potencia -2,
2 elevado al cuadrado es 4
y 4 ésta a su vez elevado a la potencia -2.
Ok, esto por esta primera parte
y ahora vamos a fijarnos en esta parte de aquí,
porque quiero que te des cuenta
que éste 1/8...
y déjame cambiar de color para que lo veas mejor...
este 1/8 lo puedo ver...
vamos a escribirlo aquí...
1/8 lo podemos ver como
1 entre 2  elevado al cubo,
o lo que es lo mismo 2 elevado a la -3.
Recuerda que cuando tengo una potencia negativa,
puedo pasar esta expresión con una potencia positiva,
si la tomó con un denominador de una fracción,
que tenga un numerador de 1.
Y bueno, aquí ya puedo ver a 1/8
como una potencia de 2.
También lo podríamos ver de la siguiente manera,
esto es exactamente lo mismo...
1/8 y voy a partir de aquí...
lo podemos ver como 8 elevado a la potencia -1,
lo único que estoy haciendo es dándome cuenta
que aquí el 8 tiene en la primera potencia,
está elevado a la primera potencia,
y entonces como está dividiendo,
yo lo puedo pasar con una potencia negativa
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2 elevado al cubo,
esto lo que representa a 8
elevado a la - 1,
fíjate que 2 elevado al cubo es 8,
8 elevado a la - 1, lo cual es exactamente lo mismo por una propiedad de las leyes de los exponentes,
que me dice que una base
elevada a una potencia, elevado a su vez a otra potencia,
es exactamente lo mismo que la base,
la base se conserva y las potencias se multiplican.
Aquí tendría 3 por -1, lo cual es -3
y llegamos justo a la misma respuesta.
1/8 es 2 elevado a la -3
y es justo lo que quería, ¡perfecto!.
Entonces en lugar de este 1/8, voy a escribirlo como
2 elevado, esto 2 elevado a la -3,
Oh, déjame ponerlo con el mismo color...
esperen vamos a escribirlo como 2 elevado a la -3, ok...
y aquí tengo un por...
y de igual manera para 1/9,
si yo tengo 1/9
y déjame atraparlo con este color...
1/9 lo podemos ver como 1 entre 3 elevado al cuadrado,
que es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 elevado a la - 2.
Recuerda que aquí estoy utilizando
la ley de los exponentes que me dice que, cuando tengo una base elevada a una potencia positiva
dividiendo, la puedo escribir como la misma base elevada a la misma potencia,
solamente que negativa,
o bueno, también lo podemos ver como que 1/9,
1/9 es exactamente lo mismo
que 9 elevado a la -1 por la misma propiedad
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que
3 elevado al cuadrado,
esto a su vez elevado a la potencia -1,
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que 3 elevado a la -2,
utilizando la propiedad de las leyes de los exponentes que me dice que, cuando tengo una base
elevada a una potencia, elevada a otra potencia,
es igual a la base
elevada a la multiplicación de las potencias ¡perfecto!
Entonces en lugar de 1/9 voy a escribir 3 elevado a la -2...
3 elevado a la - 2 ¡de lujo!
Entonces esto por 3 elevado a la -2
y todo esto,
todo esto a su vez está elevado a la quinta potencia,
todo esto está elevado a la quinta potencia.
Y bueno date cuenta que aquí ya está muy padre todo este asunto,
porque ya tenemos toda esta expresión escrita,
en base 2 y en base 3,
ya todo esto tiene que ver solamente
con potencias de 2 y con potencias de 3,
que era justo lo que queríamos.
Entonces parece ser que esto va bastante bien,
aquí tengo 3 elevado a la potencia -2
y a esto lo voy a multiplicar por...
y aquí tengo 2 elevado al cuadrado,
elevado a su vez a la - 2
y esa propiedad ya la hemos utilizado,
la utilizamos justo aquí,
cuando tengo una base elevada a un exponente,
esto a su vez elevado a otro exponente,
los exponentes pasan multiplicándose
es decir, que esto es lo mismo que 2 elevado a la 2 por - 2,
me queda -4, 2 elevado a la - 4
porque los exponentes pasan multiplicándose.
Y ahora a esto lo voy a multiplicar por...
y aquí date cuenta que puede ocupar otra vez la misma propiedad que utilizamos justo aquí,
si tenemos un producto de 2 números
elevados a una potencia, esto es exactamente lo mismo que los números elevados en la potencia,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que el producto
de los números elevados a esa misma potencia,
es decir, que a esto lo podemos ver como 2 elevado a la - 3,
esto a su vez elevado a la quinta potencia,
y a esto multiplicado por 3 elevado a la -2...
3 elevado a la -2,
esto, a su vez elevado, a la quinta potencia...
esto a su vez elevado a la quinta potencia,
vamos muy bien, ¡de lujo!
Y ahora voy a utilizar la ley de los exponentes relacionado con esta expresión que tengo aquí,
y esta expresión que tengo aquí, que por cierto,
ya hemos utilizado varias veces.
Así que bueno esto me queda
3 elevado a la -2... 3 elevado a la -2
que a su vez multiplica...
que a su vez multiplica
a 2 elevado a la - 4,
que a su vez multiplica...
y esto lo puedo ver como
2 elevado a la -3, por 5 lo cual es -15.
Ocupando la regla correspondiente,
y a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por 3 elevado a la -2 por 5, lo cual es -10.
Recuerda que cuando tengo una base
elevada a una potencia, elevada a una potencia,
es lo mismo que la base elevada
a la multiplicación de las potencias, -2 por 5,
esto es exactamente igual a -10
y de aquí ya puedes ver el patrón,
seguramente estás viendo que
ya casi acabamos este problema,
porque si ahora esto lo igualó a esta parte de aquí, déjame...
copiarlo y voy a ver si lo puedo pegar...
¡Ok! ¡De lujo!.
Esto es exactamente lo mismo o quiero hacerle lo mismo a esta igualdad que tengo aquí.
Entonces ya estamos muy cerca del final,
porque aquí lo que voy a poder hacer es relacionar las
2 expresiones que tienen la misma base...
vamos a utilizar un color distinto...
me gusta el blanco...
Voy a utilizar esta expresión que tiene base 3,
que tengo aquí
y esta expresión que tiene base 3 que tengo aquí,
y las voy a reducir,
y me va a quedar que esto es lo mismo que 3
elevado a la - 2 mas -10,
recuerda que hay una ley de los exponentes
que me dice que cuando tengo una base
elevada a una potencia
por la misma base elevada otra potencia,
las potencias se suman.
En este caso tengo -2 más -10,
lo cual es -2 menos 10 que es -12...
-12,
-2 más -10 esto es igual a -12.
¡De lujo!
Y por otra parte puedo relacionar a las 2 expresiones que tienen la misma base 2 que tengo justo aquí.
Si nosotros hacemos lo mismo, esto es 3 elevado a la -12 por
2 elevado a la "a" y tengo una base,
elevada a una potencia,
por la misma base elevada a otra potencia,
las potencias se van a sumar.
-4 más -15... - 4 más -15
esto es exactamente lo mismo que -19...
...-19... -19
¿Ok? Y esto esto tiene que ser igual
a esta expresión que tenemos acá arriba.
Justo a lo que teníamos en un principio y aquí ya puedo hacer una comparación de potencias.
Ya puedo igualar las potencias para que
esta igualdad se cumpla.
Si tengo 3 elevado a la -12 por 2 elevado a la - 19,
y esto quiero que sea igual
a 2 elevado a la "a" por 3 elevado a la "b",
entonces ya me puedo atrever a decir que "a"...
"a" debe de valer -19
que es la potencia del 2, ten cuidado,
-19... déjame tomar el mismo color...
-19...
y por otra parte "b"...
"b" debe de valer  la potencia del 3 que es -12...
debe de valer -12 para que se cumpla esta igualdad.
Y ahora si, ya puedo ocupar
que para que se cumpla esta igualdad,
las potencias deben de ser iguales
y entonces obtengo justo esto que tengo aquí
y ya llegué al resultado,
"a" igual a -19 y "b" igual a -12
hacen que se cumpla esta igualdad que tengo aquí,
y todo gracias a que utilizamos
el conocimiento que hemos obtenido
acerca de las leyes de los exponentes.